R
WONDERFUL AUDIENCE.
GOOD NIGHT FROM FLORIDA.
SEE YOU TOMORROW NIGHT AT
10:00 P.M. EASTERN.
>> A TRANSITIONAL FIGURE, I
DON'T THINK SO.
TRANSFORMATIONAL IS WHAT
JOE BIDEN IS HEADING OUT TO DO
AND BY THE WAY, IF YOU LOOK AT
HOW THE METRICS OF HIS PROGRESS
IS THAT HE ALWAYS OVERSHOOT THE
RUNWAY INSTEAD OF UNDERPERFORMS.
>> Greg: THE THING IS WHEN YOU
OVERSHOOT THE RUNWAY, EVERYONE
ON THE PLANE DIES.
[APPLAUSE]
TALK ABOUT WEIRD.
>> MEDICAID CONTEMPLATED BUT
THIS PLANE IS GOING TO HELP
THOSE FAMILIES AND CREATE JOBS
FOR OUR CAREGIVERS WITH BETTER
WAGES AND BETTER BENEFITS.
CONTINUING TO CYCLE GROWTH.
>> Greg: EVERYONE THERE WAS
FULLY VACCINATED AND YET WE SEE
A NEAR EMPTY ROOM FILLED WITH
FEARFUL EYEBALLS.
IT DID REMIND ME OF HIS CAMPAIGN
RALLIES.
BUT I WOULD WEAR A MASK TOO TO
COVER THE SMELL OF [BLEEP].
DID YOU HEAR THIS?
>> I WON'T IGNORE WHAT OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES HAVE
DETERMINED TO BE THE MOSTLY FULL
TERRORIST THREAT TO THE HOMELAND
TODAY.
WHITE SUPREMACY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ARRIVE AT
EITHER.
>> Greg: THAT'S A FIRST,
TELLING THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT
THE PROBLEM IS WITHIN THE
AMERICAN PUBC.
MY FEELING IS IF YOU'RE THAT
UNIFIER IN CHARGE YOU BETTER
BACK IT UP WITH DATA OR SHUT THE
HELL UP BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBERS TO ALLOW THE
MEDIA TO SMEAR MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE AND MAYBE THAT'S THE
POINT.
UNIFY BUT THEN CRUCIFIED.
SO IT'S ANOTHER CONFUSED TITHING
FROM THE PRESIDENT IN THE
PLASTIC BUBBLE.
MORE MIXED MESSAGES THAN A
STRIPPER.
SERIOUSLY.
SHE GIVES ME ALL THIS ATTENTION
THEN SHE DOES THE SAME THING
WITH ANOTHER GUY.
IT WASN'T ALL BAD BECAUSE THE
BAR FOR ALL BAD IS NOW GONE.
IT WAS BARELY CAPABLE.
LIKE WATCHING GRANDPA READ HIS
OWN EULOGY IF THE FUNERAL HOME
HAD A TELEPROMPTER AND GRANDPA
HAD LEFT EVERYTHING TO HIS CAT.
IT HAD ALL THE DRAMA AND URGENCY
OF A TUPPERWARE PARTY HOSTED BY
THE LADY WHO HAS FALLEN BUT
CAN'T GET UP.
THE GREATEST ACHIEVEMENT HE TOOK
CREDIT FOR.
>> AFTER I PROMISED TO GET
100 MILLION COVID-19 VACCINE
SHOTS IN PEOPLE'S ARMS IN 100
DAYS, WE WILL HAVE PROVIDED OVER
220 MILLION COVID SHOTS.
MARSHALING EVERY FEDERAL
RESOURCE.
GOTTEN VACCINES TO NEARLY 40,000
PHARMACIES AND OVER 700
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS.
>> Greg: NOW WE HAVE TWO
DR. BIDENS.
THANK YOU FOR ALSO DISCOVERING
THE POLIO, TETANUS, MEASLES
VACCINE.
ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL YOU
DISCOVERED PENICILLIN.
TALK ABOUT PLAGIARIZING.
HE'S LIKE A RELIEF PITCHER WHO
COMES IN AND GETS THE LAST OUT
ON A NO-HITTER.
THE MAIN THING THAT HELPED BEAT
THE PANDEMIC WHERE THE VACCINES
ORDERED AND SPED UP BY NOTED
SCIENCE HATER DONALD TRUMP ERWIN
TRUMP ANNOUNCED OPERATION
WARP SPEED HE WAS MARKED BY
FAMOUS SCIENTIST LIKE DR. JOY
BEHAR AND DR. WHOOPI GOLDBERG
WHO ASSURED US THAT SUCH
VACCINES WOULD TAKE YEARS AND
YEARS.
TRUMP DID IT IN NINE MONTHS.
JOE BIDEN TOOK CREDIT FOR IT FOR
JUST 100 DAYS.
THAT'S A FACT.
>> OF COURSE EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THAT OPERATION
WARP SPEED HAPPENED UNDER
JOE BIDEN BUT GETTING VACCINES
INTO ARMS WAS A BIDEN OPERATION.
>> Greg: ACTUALLY OPERATION
WARP SPEED STARTED IN MAY 2020.
THE ONLY THING JOE DOES AT
WARP SPEED IS RAISE TAXES.
OR ROLL DOWN THE CELLAR STAIRS
AFTER TRIPPING ON HIS BATHROBE.
THE LAST OPERATION JOE HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH TOOK PLACE
AT A HAIR LOSS CLINIC.
I THINK IT WAS CALLED OPERATION
JOE PLUGS.
CNN LET THAT SLIDE BECAUSE
GLORIA HASN'T SAID ANYTHING OF
MERIT SINCE THE EARLY '80s.
HER EARLY 80s.
SO HOW DID THE MEDIA TAKE TO
JOE?
AS A YOUNG SENATOR BIDEN USED TO
SAY ALL THE TIME TO FDR, ARE YOU
SITTING DOWN?
TURNS OUT THEY LIKED HIM.
>> AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
THE USE OF TONE.
AT TIMES FOR SPEAKING TO A
WHISPER.
>> EVERY SINGLE SENTENCE HAD A
VERY CLEAR POINT TO IT AND EVERY
LINE OF IT HAD THE BIDEN
HUMILITY.
>> IT WAS REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
>> HE'S TRYING TO BRING THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER.
IT WAS A MAKE AMERICA FEEL
GOOD NIGHT.
>> Greg: FORGET COVID.
THEY SUFFER FROM FAWNING
STUPIDITY WHICH CAN BE JUST AS
HARMFUL SINCE IT'S HARD TO
BREATHE WHEN YOU'RE KISSING THAT
MUCH ASS.
THEN THERE IS TIM SCOTT'S
REBUTTAL AND THE MEDIA'S
CONVULSIVE REACTION.
ALL HE HAD TO DO WAS WONDER IF
HE'S ALSO EXPERIENCED A
DIFFERENT KIND OF INTOLERANCE.
>> I'VE ALSO EXPERIENCED A
I GET CALLED UNCLE TOM AND THE
AND WORD BY PROGRESSIVES AND
LIBERALS.
THE NATIONAL NEWSPAPER SUGGESTED
THAT MY FAMILY'S POVERTY WAS
ACTUALLY PRIVILEGE BECAUSE A
RELATIVE OWN LAND GENERATIONS
BEFORE MY TIME.
>> Greg: EVERY TIME SCOTT
BRAVELY COUNTERS THE NARRATIVE
THAT AMERICA IS HORRIBLY RACIST
HE GETS CRUCIFIED BY THE LOCAL,
PEACE-LOVING, TOLERANT DEMS.
>> THERE IS SOME STUFF THERE
THAT MAY MAKE SENSE AND A SLIVER
OF REPUBLICAN WORLD BUT IN THE
NEWS WORLD I DON'T THINK IT WILL
RING.
>> DOES THE SPEECH DELIVERED
FROM A PLANET WHERE FACTS DON'T
MATTER WHICH IS WHERE THE
CURRENT REPUBLICAN PARTY
RESIDES.
IT'S HIS RESPONSIBILITY TO GET
HIS FACTS STRAIGHT.
>> AMERICA IS NOT A RACIST
COMPANY, STANDARD.
I'M NOT SURE WITH THE PURPOSE OF
THIS WAS.
I AM SHOCKED AND A BIT
EMBARRASSED FOR HIM.
THIS WAS A LOST OPPORTUNITY.
>> Greg: I'M SHOCKED SHE'S
EMBARRASSED.
THERE YOU GO, THE START CONTRAST
BETWEEN MEDIA TREATMENT OF AN
OLD WHITE MALE THEY CAN CONTROL
ANY YOUNG BLACK MAN THAT THEY
CAN'T.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY HATED
SENATOR SCOTT'S REBUTTAL BUT
TODAY AT CNN ALL OF THE BLM
FLAGS ARE AT HALF MAST.
JOE PRESENT A VISION THAT GETS A
STAMP OF APPROVAL FROM THE LOCAL
GLASS AS HE ABANDONS ANY DEFENSE
OF THE WORKING CLASS.
CLASSES DEAD.
LONG LIVE RACE.
TIM SCOTT BY REJECTING THE
LANGUAGE OF VICTIMHOOD AND HATE
SCARES THE MEDIA MORE THAN
PRODUCT VERITAS' NEXT RELEASE.
A BLACK GUY IS ONTO THEM.
>> TODAY KIDS ARE BEING TAUGHT
THAT THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN
DEFINES THEM AGAIN.
AND IF THEY LOOK A CERTAIN WAY,
THEY ARE UNDER PRESSURE.
DOUBLING DOWN ON THE DIVISIONS
WE HAVE WORKED SO HARD TO HEAL.
YOU KNOW THIS STUFF IS WRONG.
HEAR ME CLEARLY.
AMERICA IS NOT A RACIST COUNTRY.
>> Greg: WHOA, DID HE JUST SAY
AMERICA IS NOT A RACIST COUNTRY?
>> HEAR ME CLEARLY.
AMERICA IS NOT A RACIST COUNTRY.
>> Greg: I HEARD HIM CLEARLY.
HOW DARE HE SAY SOMETHING SO
POSITIVE ABOUT AMERICA?
DIDN'T HE GET THE MEMO OR AT
LEAST WATCH THE OSCARS?
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY, HAS HE EVER
EVEN MET A BLACK PERSON?
EXCEPT HIS FAMILY AND MANY OF
HIS FRIENDS AND THOUSANDS OF HIS
CONSTITUENTS.
WE ARE ALL RACIST.
JUST ASK ANY ANGRY WHITE MALE.
♪ ♪
>> SO THE WHOLE COUNTRY AS MY
FAMILY NOW?
I DON'T KNOW.
WE SURE HAVEN'T BEEN ACTING LIKE
IT LATELY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THERE'S A REASON THERE'S A
PHRASE "LOVE THY NEIGHBOR."
BECAUSE YOU NEED HELP WITH THAT,
RIGHT?
NOBODY'S GOT TO REMIND ME LOVE
THY FAMILY.
BUT LOVE THY NEIGHBOR, THAT'S A
DIFFERENT THING.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE REMINDED OF
THAT BECAUSE IT TAKES WORK.
AND COMPROMISE.
AND RESPECTING EACH OTHER'S
DIFFERENCES.
HI.
THAT'S VERY CUTE.
WHY WOULD YOU FEED SQUIRRELS?
>> WHAT A RACIST.
YOU KNOW ITS RACIST?
SAYING WE GET TO LIVE IN THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON EARTH.
>> WE GET TO LIVE IN THE
GREATEST COUNTRY OWNERS.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT OUR FINEST
HOUR HAS YET TO COME.
ORIGINAL SIN IS NEVER THE END OF
THE STORY.
NOT IN OUR SOULS AND NOT FOR OUR
NATION.
THE REAL STORY IS ALWAYS
REDEMPTION.
>> Greg: EVERYTHING SCOTT SAID
WAS POSITIVE AND UNIFYING AND IT
WAS DESPISED BY THE MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRATS.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE THEY NEED AN ENEMY IN
THAT ENEMY IS US.
THEY HATE REDEMPTION BECAUSE
IT'S WHAT PREVENTS THE PROPHETS
ONE GETS FROM DIVISION.
IT'S ALSO NOW SOMETHING THE LEFT
CONDEMNS FROM A MAN WHO HAS THE
AUDACITY TO BE BLACK AND SAY
SUCH THINGS.
YOU CAN'T PUSH REVOLUTION IN
AMERICA IF YOU BELIEVE AMERICANS
ARE ACTUALLY REDEEMABLE.
INSTEAD YOU MUST BELVE THAT
EVEN THE BLACK GUY IS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
DR. KING, PLEASE PICK UP THE
WHITE COURTESY PHONE OR WHATEVER
COLOR COURTESY PHONE YOU PREFER.
WE NEED YOU MORE THAN EVER.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
FOX NEWS ANCHOR JULIE BANDERAS.
HE IS SO SMART HE TELLS SIMON
WHAT TO SAY, THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY STUDIES OF THE AMERICAN
RICE INSTITUTE, RYAN STREETER.
SHE BELIEVES LAUGHTER IS THE
BEST MEDICINE BUT ALSO PERCOCET,
XANAX AND VALIUM.
KAT TIMPF.
EVERYWHERE HE GOES IS AN
OBSERVATION DECK.
TYRUS.
TYRUS, I'M GOING TO GO TO YOU
FIRST BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ON FOR A COUPLE DAYS.
HOW DID YOU LIKE THE SPEECH IS?
>> I'M GOING TO KEEP IT REAL.
I WATCH THEM BOTH IN THEIR
ENTIRETY, NO MATTER HOW MUCH I
WANTED TO, I SAT THROUGH IT AND
I WANTED TO PROVE A POINT TO
MYSELF.
THERE WERE SOME THINGS IN
BIDEN'S SPEECH THAT I THOUGHT
WERE ALL RIGHT.
I THINK WE SHOULD START OUR KIDS
EARLY.
I DO LIKE THE SOUND OF GOING TO
SCHOOL AT 3 YEARS OLD.
GIVES US A COMPETITIVE EDGE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE FREE
COLLEGE AFTERWARDS BUT I THINK
WHEN YOU GET OLDER YOU NEED TO
WORK YOUR WAY AND GET THROUGH
SOME BUMPS.
BUT THERE WERE SOME THINGS, NOT
BAD.
AND THEN BROTHER SCOTT CAME ON
AND I WAS LIKE WOW, NICE JOB.
BOTH GUYS, THE PRESIDENT AND
MR. SCOTT WERE PUSHING
BIPARTISANSHIP.
AT THE SAME TIME PROTECTING
THEIR BRAND.
I ALSO WATCHED AN OLD WHITE MAN
STANDING ON A PODIUM SPEAKING
WITH A WOMAN OF COLOR, A REALLY
OLD WHITE WOMAN, ONE AND TWO IN
CASE SOMETHING GOES WRONG AND
THEN THE REBUTTAL FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WAS A PROUD
BLACK MAN.
SITTING IN MY CHAIR AND I'M
GOING WOW, WE MADE IT.
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AS YOU CAN GET
AND WE ARE REPRESENTED.
NICE JOB.
BUT THEN I WATCHED WHAT HAPPENED
AFTERWARDS.
NO ONE WAS TALKING ABOUT
BIPARTISANSHIP.
THEY WENT AFTER TIM SCOTT.
THEY DIDN'T GO AFTER BIDEN.
WHAT I LEARNED, WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED OUT IS THAT RACISM IS
NOT JUST FOR WHITE PEOPLE
ANYMORE.
CALLING HIM UNCLE TIM.
THEN I WILL BE UNCLE TYRUS WITH
HIM BECAUSE HE TOLD THE TRUTH.
THIS IS NOT A RACIST COUNTRY.
WE ARE HOWEVER OBSTACLES AND
ISSUES.
SOMEBODY MIGHT HATE YOU BECAUSE
OF THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN OR THE
SIZE OF YOUR BELLY OR THE SEX
YOU ARE.
WE ALL HAVE A EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE SAW THE EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES
BUT THAT WASN'T WHAT MAINSTREAM
MEDIA WAS INTERESTED IN.
I LISTEN TO SO-CALLED BLACK MEN
WHO CALL THEMSELVES LIBERALS,
FIGHTING FOR FREEDOM AND
OPPORTUNITY TRASHING HIM LIKE HE
WAS IGNORED AND HE WAS A WHITE
MAN'S DOG.
WHERE DOES THAT LANGUAGE COME
FROM?
JIM CROW ERA.
THAT'S HOW THEY TALKED AND IT
WAS ACCEPTABLE AND NOW THEY DO
IT POLITELY BECAUSE THE BROTHER
HAD A DIFFERENCE OF OPINIONS AND
IT'S DISGUSTING.
I WAS SADDENED BY WHAT THESE
SO-CALLED NEWS ANCHORS.
NOT OPINION LIKE THIS.
WE TELL JOKES AND WE OWN IT.
THEY PUSH THEMSELVES AS ANCHORS,
PEOPLE OF NEWS.
THEY PUSHED IT.
DIVISION CELLS.
THEY COULDN'T SAY THAT BOTH GUYS
WERE ELOQUENT AND BOTH HAD A LOT
TO SAY AND WE CAN BUILD FROM
THIS MOMENT BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T
SELL AND THAT'S SAD TO ME.
>> Greg: VERY POIGNANT.
>> THAT WAS DEEP.
>> Greg: IT WAS DEEP.
I DON'T EXPECT THAT FROM YOU.
I KNOW LAST NIGHT YOU ARE
PROBABLY IN SOME HOTEL ROOM
BOMBED OUT OF YOUR SKULL AND YOU
BARELY KNEW WHERE YOU WERE.
>> THAT'S CLOSE BUT I WAS AT
HOME.
I PUT THE KIDS TO BED AND I
WATCHED 10 MINUTES MIKE TURNED
ON "THE CROWN."
I WATCH THE AFTERMATH, THE ASS
KISSING.
I KIND OF IDENTIFIES AN
88-YEAR-OLD BOY AND I'M WATCHED
TWO PEOPLE KISS ON CAMERA IT
TRULY GROSSES ME OUT.
ANYWAY, I JUST COULDN'T WATCH.
LIKE THE 8-YEAR-OLD BOY AND HE
WAS LIKE, THIS IS GROSS AND WHY
ARE WE SEEING SO MUCH MAKING OUT
ON CABLE TV.
IT'S INAPPROPRIATE.
>> Greg: DON'T IDENTIFY AS AN
8-YEAR-OLD BOY NEAR THE LINCOLN
PROJECT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
WHAT'S YOUR OBJECTIVE TAKE ON
ALL OF THIS.
>> I THINK THE RESPONSE TO
SENATOR SCOTT WAS VERY
PREDICTABLE.
THE NONRESPONSE TO
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS THIS
MORNING WHO REAFFIRMED THE SAME
THING.
WHEN ASKED, IS AMERICA A RACIST
COUNTRY.
SHE SAID NO, AMERICA IS NOT A
RACIST COUNTRY.
UNCLE "TOMALA" WASN'T TRENDING
ON TWITTER.
TIM SCOTT IS A PRETTY SERIOUS
GUY.
HE CARES ABOUT PUBLIC POLICY AND
IDEAS AND WANTS TO SEE THINGS
CHANGE.
HE GOT INTO POLITICS FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS.
THAT'S NOT A PARTICULARLY COMMON
TRAIT IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
RIGHT NOW.
THE PARTY IS IN A LITTLE BIT OF
DISARRAY.
SO THEY'VE BEEN SPENDING THE
LAST FOUR YEARS OR SO COMING UP,
IT'S KIND OF A MISDIAGNOSIS OF
THE KIND OF TRUMPIAN APPEAL TO
THE WORKING CLASS.
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING ON
CONSERVATIVE MINIMUM WAGES,
CONSERVATIVE CHILD CREDITS.
CONSERVATIVE WAGE SUBSIDIES AND
THESE THINGS HAVE NOW CREATED AN
APPETITE FOR KINDS OF THINGS
JOE BIDEN IS PUTTING ON.
WHAT THEY COULD JUST BE DOING IS
WORKING ON TRYING TO GET THEIR
AGENDA THROUGH RATHER THAN
TRYING TO ATTACK TIM SCOTT.
HE'S ACTUALLY SPEAKING FOR MOST
MIDDLE AMERICANS.
IF YOU LOOK AT HOW PEOPLE
RESPOND TO SURVEYS ABOUT THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
MOST BLACK AMERICANS AND
HISPANIC-AMERICANS BELIEVE THEY
ARE ON THEIR WAY.
HE WAS SPEAKING THEIR LANGUAGE.
ATTACKING HIM IN THIS ANTIRACIST
WAY WITHOUT ESSENTIALLY TALKING
ABOUT THE AGENDA WHICH HAS A
WIDE APPEAL TO AMERICANS RIGHT
NOW.
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT.
THEY SHOULD'VE BEEN EASIER.
IT SHOWS YOU WHERE THEY ARE AND
WHERE WE'VE GONE.
>> Greg: KAT, WHERE WE GONE?
>> Kat: WHERE HAVE I GONE?
I KIND OF WENT INTO A RAGE A
LITTLE LATE YESTERDAY WHEN
JOE BIDEN SAID THE GOVERNMENT OF
THE PEOPLE.
HE CALLED ME THE GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS THE MEANEST THING
ANYONE HAS EVER SAID ABOUT ME.
EVER.
I DON'T STEAL MONEY FROM OTHER
PEOPLE.
HE STOOD UP THERE AND MADE IT
CLEAR THAT HE IS VERY MUCH
PLANNING ON STEALING A LOT OF
MONEY FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
I DON'T WANT OTHER PEOPLE TO
SPEND MY MONEY, LET ALONE PEOPLE
WHO THINK THEY NEED TO WEAR
MASKS WHEN THEY ARE VACCINATED
IN A ROOM FULL OF OTHER PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALL COMPLETELY
VACCINATED.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
DOING TO SEND A MESSAGE.
WHAT MESSAGE ARE YOU SENDING?
GET VACCINATED.
NOTHING WILL CHANGE FOR YOU?
I WOULDN'T CARE IF IT WAS JUST
STUPID BECAUSE IT IS STUPID BUT
IT'S ALSO HARMFUL.
>> Greg: I FELT LIKE I WAS
WATCHING BENEATH THE
"PLANET OF THE APES," THE SECOND
ONE WITH THE PEOPLE WHO LIVED
UNDERGROUND.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT QUESTION
LIKE THEY WERE SCARY LOOKING.
>> THEY ATE THE PRETT